Thank you so much for the kind introduction and for being here today.
Um,
I hope you saw the large stack of books and that you can grab one on your way
out if you feel so inclined.
Um,
so I'll be introducing with 20 minutes of history,
but is Eileen indicated,
I think this will have significance for how we talk about autism and Asperger
Syndrome today and it,
this book has already gotten quite a bit of a conversation going with society's
renaming themselves and conversation online with people who have self identified
with Asperger's.
Um,
so I hope we can get to bigger questions of neuro diversity through this.
One of the things that we can all agree on is that um,
Hans aspergers idea of autism took hold in the 1990s.
The diagnostic criteria were expanded,
so for decades,
sorry about that.
We in the United States went by the American Leo Kanner's definition of autism
and his idea of autism,
which was much narrower than how we understand it today.
Kanner was looking at children who were relatively similar to one another.
They tended to have more severe cognitive impairments.
They were less verbal or nonverbal.
And Asperger had a much broader idea of autism.
And he included children with milder challenges,
which is one of the reasons behind this increase in diagnosis.
So Asperger to take you back to the turn of the century,
was born in 1906 and how spring 50 miles outside of Vienna.
He left home at age 19.
Very precocious for medical studies at the University of Vienna in Vienna was a
cultural capital of Europe at this time,
but it also fell after World War One and to political and economic crises in
street children flooded Vienna's institutions.
There were a number of orphans from the war and just thousands of children
destitute and the need of help.
So you have a very progressive welfare system that gets developed in Vienna to
help these children,
including leak leading psycho analysis and psychiatrists who get involved.
You can see Sigmund and Anna Freud there who do a lot of volunteer work at this
time.
So Asperger becomes part of the circle.
Um,
he goes to work at the University of Vienna Children's Hospital in 1931 and he
was one of the first hires by France hamburger and he was part of this effort to
help v and V and these children in need.
France hamburger,
however,
was on the far right of the political spectrum.
He joined the Nazi party quite early and had his reputation as a real radical
and Humberg or began purging the esteemed faculty of the University of Vienna
Children's hospital.
Um,
predominantly Jews and liberals and hiring people on the far right instead.
And Asperger was one of hamburgers.
First hires and Asperger had solid right,
um,
credentials being members of anti liberal,
anti-socialist,
anti modern and antisemitic organizations.
And Hamburger promoted Asperger very quickly at a very young age.
At Age 28,
he was named the Head of the curative education clinic over the heads of
longtime staffers who had worked there for decades.
So please bear with me.
I love this chart,
although it's a lot to absorb,
but let me just break it down.
You can see these thin lines.
This is a,
a network graph and intellectual network graph of relationships between V and
e's,
um,
psychiatrists and psychoanalysis.
Vienna really was the cradle of psycho analysis at this time.
And so you can see the people with big letters,
um,
are the real nodes in this connection.
And here you have the liberal Jewish psychoanalysis whose names you would know,
right Anna,
Freud's,
Sigmund Freud and their associates.
And then you have Asperger,
the young man,
that picture there and hamburger who are really off on the periphery of
mainstream psychoanalysis.
And they were considered kind of crackpots by the people whose names we would
most respect today.
And so what happened during the Third Reich,
and what I'll be talking about is these guys are all forced out of their
positions and they emigrate to the United States in the UK.
And Asperger's branch of psychiatry comes to the fore because it has real Nazi
resonances.
And so what this slide also shows is this is happening in the thirties before
the Nazis Annex Vienna.
And so VN is political and social split in the sciences,
predates the advent of Nazi ism and formal politics.
In Vienna,
people are already doing this.
Okay.
So what did aspergers branch of Psychiatry believe?
The child psychiatrist he was hanging out with were diagnosing children who they
said lacked social spirit,
who they were unable to participate in group activities such as the Hitler
youth.
And they would even consult for organizations like the Hitler youth or League of
German girls trying to get these kids to be more social and feel I'm part of the
collective over the individual.
So Paul Schroeder on the upper left is really the father of Nazi psychiatry and
he called this readiness to serve the community.
And the word he used was [inaudible],
which is one German.
Um,
the famously untranslatable words in German.
but in the 18th century it meant something like soul.
Um,
and then Nazi psychiatrist added the social dimension.
So it's really kind of a metaphysical connection that I'm feeling with the
audience right now.
We're sharing and some higher spirit.
And so this was this idea of good moot and um,
this was important in the Nazi state.
The state really aimed for this purified homogenous folk that was not about
conformity.
It was about fascist feeling.
It was about togetherness.
It was about a shared purpose and grew moot,
would take you beyond conformity.
So,
um,
Hans Hind set worked with Schroeder Asperger in turned with both of them.
Hans Hindsa would go on to become one of the top three individuals involved in
the murder of disabled children and the right.
And so very early on in 1934,
um,
Asperger is working with these guys and being infused with their ideas.
So the other people pictured here,
I won't go through them,
but just trust me.
They all wrote about good mood and they started to diagnose children who lacked
gumboot.
And um,
they started publishing articles in the thirties long before Asperger every book
ever published and they would diagnose children's percent of good moods and the
heritability of gumboot.
And they had a whole vocabulary around children's social spirit and even through
around the word autism,
um,
as meaning community averse and weak.
And so my point here is really to say that the idea of autism predated
Asperger's work.
It was already in the air of Nazi psychiatry.
So now we're in March of 1938 in the Nazis roll in to Vienna on March 13th.
And Asperger witnessed tremendous change immediately at the University of
Vienna,
the medical school removed 78% of its faculty,
predominantly Jews.
And remember,
hamburger at the children's hospital had already purged all the Jews.
So this is on top of what had been happening.
Um,
including three Nobel prize winners,
Asperger and hamburgers.
A clinic went through the purchase unscathed because they had already
voluntarily purge.
They're liberals and they're Jews.
And in fact,
as I showed you on the chart with this purge of 78% of the faculty at the
University Get van,
now they had greater opportunities.
Okay.
So I hate texts slides,
but,
but bear with me cause I think this is important.
So for Asperger,
okay,
creating a diagnosis was a new professional opportunity.
So 1937,
one year before the Nazi annexation,
he wrote,
um,
he didn't believe in diagnosing children.
There is approaches is there are different personalities.
It is impossible to establish a rigid set of criteria for a diagnosis.
So we need to appreciate the uniqueness of children,
right?
We can't diagnose them.
Then
just a few months after the Nazis roll into Vienna,
Asperger introduced his own diagnosis.
This is a well characterized group of children,
right?
Well characterized who we name autistic psychopaths because the confinement of
the self has led to a narrowing of relations to their environment.
So what's striking here is Asperger calls autism,
a psychopathy,
um,
which really carries connotations and German psychiatry of criminality and
depravity.
And you're going to grow up to like roam the streets and talk to yourself.
It's,
it's something that you can't cure and you're,
um,
yeah,
you're like,
uh,
yeah,
a social on the street.
And so it has a bit of a different meaning than it does in English.
And this is a well characterized group of children.
So he's really changed his tone within a very short period of time.
At the same time,
he's changing his tone.
He joins a number of Nazi organizations in quick succession,
and he also begins to consult for the juvenile justice system.
You might imagine the Nazi justice system is not terribly lenient toward
nonconformist children.
And he also begins to work for the city's remedial schools.
So Asperger did not join the Nazi party.
And this is a reason why he has been,
as Aileen mentioned,
lionized in the history as a resistor of Nazi-ism,
um,
is I show in my book,
this was not a big deal.
Only three and 10 physicians in Vienna joined the Nazi party.
So a small minority joined the Nazi party.
Um,
and he was closely affiliated with hamburger and other individuals that
protected him politically.
He didn't need to join the Nazi party.
He was a member of all these other organizations
and he would soon begin to work at the eye of the storm of the euthanasia
program.
Okay.
So this is where the talk becomes difficult.
Just trigger warnings I need to do with my work.
Um,
but I'm now going to talk about the Nazi program of child euthanasia and that's
their term.
Um,
which is really a misnomer.
These children were neither terminally ill nor suffering,
okay?
They were just deemed to have mental or physical defects.
And this was the Reich's first program of mass extermination.
It predated the murder of Jews and Sinti and Roma and slobs and other groups.
Um,
and it was designed to become a permanent part of the healthcare system.
Unlike these other forms of mass extermination that were more war time
operations.
This was a deliberative scientific process.
And the idea was to rid the,
the state of who would be a drain economically and a danger to its gene pool.
Um,
so at least 5,000 children perished,
which is a very small number compared to the indiscriminate killing killing of
other groups.
But in my mind,
this is even the smallness of the number is what makes it so scary because it's
so deliberative.
Doctors were going through these case files in,
you know,
excessive detail and passing them on.
And it was,
it was a scientific process.
You were judging children as individually worthless,
worthless or worthy.
There are around 37 children's wards dotted inside the right.
This is not out somewhere in Poland or eastern Europe.
This is inside communities.
And this is Spiegel grinned in Vienna,
um,
which is right outside.
You can take tram number 47 and still get there.
And um,
it's one of the deadliest,
we're almost 800 children were killed.
So in contrast to the,
our mechanized images of the Holocaust,
I think euthanasia is,
has been overlooked and it's important to understand its dimensions.
It involved intimate killing by the doctors and nurses that saw these children
every day.
They knew their names,
they fed them,
they change their sheets and women,
this is the only program of extermination that really relied on women killings
were done.
And the youth's own beds is staff would issue overdoses of barbiturates until
the children grew ill and died,
usually have pneumonia.
And a ton of people knew this was going on.
There were protests outside of Spiegel grown.
They were rumors published,
um,
that were being denied in the newspapers.
Um,
but people had different opinions.
Some parents would actually deliver their children to the killing center and
request that their child be put to death.
Um,
the doctors were sort of offended at this because this was supposed to be a
scientific process and it was supposed to be the doctors that decided and so
they would not on our parental wishes to put a child to death.
But um,
yeah,
there you go.
Okay.
So where has Asperger in this program?
Well,
you've see me flash up hamburger who was a zealous,
um,
supporter of the program.
He transferred numerous children to Schmiegel grunt is head of the children's
hospital.
This is Max Gundel who's the city counselor on the board of Spiegel grunt.
He's the municipal director of Spiegel grunt.
This is air when you,
Kelly is,
who's the head doctor of speak Okrent.
And so Asperger co founded the Vienna Society for Curative Education With these
three guys.
He worked very closely with them.
So close with you Kelly,
if to the regime,
I don't know if you can recognize this woman if she resembles eight off,
that's his sister Paula Hitler.
Yeah.
Hitler apparently disapproved of the match because he didn't want his daughter
marrying a mass murder and had him arrested in a trip to Berlin by the Gestapo.
And sent off to the eastern front,
which is a handy way to get rid of a brother in law.
You don't want the time of course.
So,
um,
Asperger publicly called for the transfer of children to speak old grunt.
So this is a talk he gave that was re published in the Munich medical weekly it
prestigious journal saying that quote for all difficult cases,
only a long and continuous observation as proper,
like those carried out in his own clinic or the reformatory Spico grunt.
And he followed his own advice.
Uh,
he were two girls who he transferred to speak old Grund two and a half year old
heritage Kleiber.
She was the youngest of nine children,
was severely disabled by meningitis and Diptheria.
Asperger concluded the quote,
her accommodation and Spiegel grunt is absolutely necessary here to his mother
reportedly told the presiding Dr it Spiegel grunt.
If the child could not be helped,
perhaps it would be better if she should die,
as she would have nothing in this world anyway,
hair to did die two months after aspergers transfer.
Um,
and one wonders if the mother's wishes played a role in Asperger's.
Thinking because theirs are numerous cases where if the mother's overburdened at
home and has a disabled child and is unable to cope,
he would follow the wishes and institutionalize the child.
Um,
so five year old Elizabeth,
um,
he transferred to speak of grunge.
She could speak only a single word Mama,
the nurse,
it's Spiegel going wrote,
she has a friendly nature,
is very affectionate and flattering with caregivers.
If she is treated strictly,
she will cry and hug the nurse.
She was killed four months after she was admitted to Spiegel.
GRUND and her brain harvested,
kept with the collection of over 400 children's brains in the cellar of speak.
Speakable grunt.
So this is also context.
Meanwhile aspergers working on autism.
Okay,
so remember in 1937 he wrote,
it's impossible to establish a diagnosis.
Then a year later,
1938,
he comes out with his own diagnosis and it uses neutral language.
It says this is a confinement of the self,
a narrowing of relations.
That's,
that's kind of neutral language,
although he does call them psychopaths.
So as time passes,
he begins to adapt,
uh,
assume more fascist language.
So in 1940 he defines a group of abnormal children who we refer to as autistic
psychopaths.
These loaner children fall out of every community.
They live their own lives without emotional relationship to the environment.
They also react abnormally to the needs of the environment.
So basically his language has become more normative,
right?
These are abnormal children.
They're behaving abnormal and he's more concerned with social connectedness,
right?
He calls them loners,
they don't have an emotional attachment.
So he's shifted a bit.
Then in 1944,
this is a seminal treatise that is cited today on autism.
And this is his post doctoral thesis that he wrote for promotion.
At this time,
the children's hospital was really desperate to promote people because remember
the purge of liberal and Jewish faculty.
So he was sort of put up through the ranks even though his thesis was really a
rush job.
And if you read it now,
it's,
it's remarkable that it passed for science.
Um,
but he wrote the artist is only himself and not an active member of the greater
organism,
which he is influenced by in which he influences constantly.
Okay.
So here we have members and greater organisms and I mean this is fully fascist
language,
right?
Um,
and he becomes more and more concerned with aptitude for community here.
And then later in the thesis he adopts Nazi Psychiatry's,
um,
central tenant of gumboot.
He'd never written about Kahoot before,
but now he's up for promotion.
There's good mood here.
We are in he,
um,
so my argument is that basically autism was conceived as the psychological
opposite of Nazi-ism,
right?
That it's children who lack the capacity for fascism and Asperger who is fluent
in both Greek and Latin might have had this in mind as fast yo is the bundle or
the group in autos is the self turned inward.
So Asperger did prize,
one of the reasons he has this reputation today is valuing children with
disabilities is because he said some were superhuman,
right.
And we kind of have this idea of,
you know,
Asperger's today is people can press possess these savant powers and um,
are really remarkable.
And Asperger did prize the special abilities,
um,
in math and other technical subjects and said they were at the quote favorable.
And if an autistic range,
um,
he held a highly gendered view of this and declaring that the artistic
personality is an extreme variant of male intelligence,
of the male character.
Um,
and this is echoing the gender stereotypes of the day,
saying the boys had a gift for logical thinking for abstraction,
whereas girls were more for the concrete and practical.
And he said in over 200 cases of autism,
he had never seen a case in girls ever.
This was a male characteristic.
He did say after the war,
um,
while there were no female cases in Austria and the United States,
there were some cars,
girls had become more masculinized in the United States.
Yeah.
Um,
so Asperger believe that many of the boys could be remediated if they received
intensive help and therapy.
These were boys that were worth reclaiming for the national community and he was
far more dismissive of girls who showed the same traits and they were sent to
correctional facilities.
So I went through some of the case files of these children have boys and girls
who were described in the same terms and met opposite fates.
Um,
so Fritz for example,
fell out of the community.
It was impossible to get him to play in a group.
His eye gaze one was mostly into state space.
Horrow would never play with others.
These were sort of a clinic notes written on these boys,
but in his treatise,
and we know this from his case files,
he treated these boys with genuine care and kindness and employed a lot of
therapies we use today.
This is also why aspergers considered very progressive.
He gets his clinic engaged in play,
therapy's and drama and music.
Um,
he believed in giving children,
um,
special aids at school and special tutoring and you know,
one on one.
Um,
kind of what we consider play play therapy,
um,
for boys who were deemed to have potential.
Okay.
Sit here.
Some files of girls that I found.
Um,
Christine Burka was quote,
difficult to influence from the outside.
She was closed,
inhibited,
hard to reach.
Um,
you can see her clinic note,
they're kind commute,
no good.
Um,
and then you can see his official diagnosis of Christine is not as psych is not
a psychiatric diagnosis,
but it's a character variant.
This is his handwriting.
He was born left handed,
but then was forced to be right handed.
So it's terrible.
Um,
the poor historian,
um,
he,
she was egocentric,
vulgar,
oppositional and underhanded,
and she was sent to a correctional institution.
She did not receive the kind of care of the boys.
Did Al Frieda and Margarita faced even worse faiths,
um,
again,
describing them in the same language as the is the boys,
he called autistic.
He said that Margarita did not participate at all in the community of children.
Her facial expression was remarkably empty.
She would stare and passively before her.
Again,
I could just read all these quotes,
same characteristics given to Alfreda.
So here's what happened to them.
Kelly is,
remember Paula Hitler's fiance visited Asperger's clinic and she was transferred
the same day.
Margarita was introduced to your Kelly's,
um,
al Frieda was sent to obtain Thailand.
Dr Elink,
that's the killing pavilion and speak old grunt.
So those are the fates that El Frieda hands Margarita faced.
Even though they manifested,
I mean,
we can't say that these girls look like the boys,
right?
But he,
they are marking similar symptoms and they're having opposite fates.
So Asperger not only had a gendered view of autism,
um,
he had an extremely eugenicist view in general.
Again,
some people point to his,
a few sets of language about the highly original genius of children on the most
favorable and of the autistic range.
And they speculate that he used his,
um,
the autism diagnosis is a way of protecting children from the killing saying
they're so great that he was using the autism diagnosis,
like a psychiatric Schindler's list.
Right.
Um,
but this benevolent rhetoric was in keeping with Nazi psychiatry.
All these guys were writing really great things about children that this was
their rhetoric.
The children that they believed could be brought into the folk.
It was the children that they believed were irredeemable,
um,
that they exterminated.
There was a real bifurcated idea of disability in Nazi Germany.
It wasn't just that you were disabled,
you could be remediated or you were worthless.
It was,
uh,
there was a solid line there.
Um,
so those,
this has Asberger's language who were on the unfavorable end of his rage would
grow up to roam the streets as originals,
grotesque and dilapidated.
Okay.
So how did we get to where we are today?
Just briefly and then this'll be part of the extended conversation.
What I think is most telling is Asperger never really wrote about autism again
after the war.
He didn't disavow it.
He just never conducted any more research on it.
And he wrote a handful of very short papers for newsletters,
but that's really about it.
He was more interested in religious themes and social commentary and um,
you know,
so to my mind,
this really makes me question the extent to which he believed in the autism
diagnosis to begin with.
Or was this a strategic careerist moved during the Nazi period where he followed
his senior colleagues for a short period of time.
God has promotion and then revealed his true interests after the war.
Um,
so he probably would have been a footnote in the history of autism had it not
been for Lorna wing.
Um,
she was a leading British psychiatrist who'd IX conducted extensive research on
youths.
Her daughter Susie was on the spectrum and she was interested in children who
she didn't think fit into canners diagnosis.
Um,
but she did far more research than Asperger ever did.
but she came across Asberger's thesis that her husband translated her and named
her work,
what she was seeing Asperger syndrome as a professional courtesy.
Um,
she made a couple of fateful decisions with that
article is that she decided not to call Asperger's syndrome a psychopathy.
She wanted to use a neutral term.
So when the idea of aspergers hit the English speaking world,
it was Asperger's syndrome,
not Asperger's,
psychopathy.
And then she also purged her article of the pejorative language that he'd used.
So He'd been calling these kids sadistic and malicious and she purged all of
that language.
Um,
and so what we know today is Asperger's syndrome is really wings syndrome.
I would,
I would argue,
um,
and then once her work became published,
in 1981,
it's slowly grain to gain traction.
And then in the 1990s is when it really exploded.
And entered our diagnostic lexicon today.
I personally believe we should stop using the term Asperger's.
And I've written for scientific American and the New York Times and Time
magazine saying that we should no longer use this and m um,
and such.
The book's been published.
This is just a few reviews that have also gone as far as to say we should
discontinue the use of the term Asperger's and um,
we can talk about that as well.
I just want to point out the broader aim of my book is not to cause you know,
a kerfluffle today,
but to really show is,
is a warning to all of us how psychiatric diagnoses can be shaped by social and
political forces we may not be aware of.
Um,
and that they're shaped by forces beyond individual patients and doctors.
And we really need to question what may be underlying them as they change over
time.
So thank you.
It's really quite a work of scholarship.
I've dug into it over the weekend,
didn't get through the whole thing.
So you spent quite a bit of time researching it.
Tell us why you pee.
How did you come to this topic?
Because you've written another book about how the Germans built the Iron
Curtain.
So you clearly had an interest in Germany and the Nazi era,
but why this book?
Sure.
I jumped from the Cold War to the Third Reich.
Um,
so my son Eric was diagnosed with autism when he was 17 months old.
And um,
you know,
like any parent read everything I could about the diagnosis and in basically
every parent manual,
it would go on about Leo Kanner,
the American who came up with his diagnosis and the American who actually moved
from Austria Derrida.
Dot.
Yeah,
thanks to your research.
I now know that.
Okay.
Um,
and uh,
there'd always be a paragraph or two saying
there's this Hans Asperger who was working in Nazi dn and he was a really good
guy.
Um,
but not much is known about him.
And I had a conference on my first book in Vienna and I decided to look into the
story because I had heard this idea of autism was the psychiatric Schindler's
list.
It was on his Wikipedia page.
It was in all these parent manuals.
And,
um,
my very first day in the archives,
the very first file I looked at was his Nazi district party file.
And it had this extraordinary record of his reliability when it came to racial
hygiene policy and his involvement.
It's remarkable.
So among many of us know the statistics more than 6 million Jews murdered in the
Nazi regime.
But you quoted a figure that I was surprised with so low 200,000 people with
disability and I would have expected a far greater number.
Um,
but there was a notion that there were individuals in society who were not going
to contribute,
either were physically fit to or somehow had a physical disability,
intellectual disability,
missing mythic title.
That is a weird,
you know,
that the sense of like a German spirit or the soul of the society.
That's a very interesting and nuanced issue.
So some children were saved by doctor s Burger and his team at the school was
called again the,
Oh,
the cured of education,
Curative Education Clinic and a number.
We're,
uh,
we can't prove that,
but,
oh yeah.
I mean,
I don't rule it out.
I,
I don't think he went out of his way to save children necessarily,
but I wouldn't rule it out.
But we can conclusively say that dozens of children he transferred to the
killing center died.
I want to pick up on a little bit of what you said.
So the official statistics are about 200,000 people with disabilities.
I think that's a vast understatement.
And a lot of historians do too,
because they were simply starve.
Oh.
At these places like,
so these hospitals and these asylums wouldn't be adequately,
um,
you know,
rationed.
And,
um,
we also know people would deliver the elderly in their households to old age
homes.
Um,
you know,
where life expectancy would probably be lower than if they'd received great
achievements.
So it's hard to know it.
Yeah.
And how do you research and what did you find in your research of this folk,
this German folk who would,
um,
turn over the infirm to an institutional solution and in,
in fact,
even willingly.
And you and I,
I also have a child with a form of autism and I'm well aware of the challenges
but also some of the joys and raising these children.
But I have seen parents who walk away as well.
We do walk away from their kids.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah,
it's remarkable.
I mean I do want to say,
um,
you know,
there was a wide range of parental responses.
So I went through some of the letters that parents had sent to the director of
Spiegel grand after the deaths of their children and some are really heart
wrenching and tear stained and you know,
how could this possibly have happened.
Um,
and then there are some thank you notes.
so I think
you know,
what,
what comes permissible cam lit up our darkest impulses so far.
Do you think in our own evolution awareness of the incidents of autism in
society?
Certainly California has been one of the states that has tracked the increased
incidents probably most closely of any US state.
Why was Dr Asper a till now given such a benign moniker?
I always understood he was one,
a doctor who actually classified in typified the range of,
uh,
autism across this spectrum.
Sure.
So if you read his 1944 thesis,
um,
it reads extremely generously,
you know,
he focused on,
he focuses on children who are in the higher end of his range.
Right.
And he thought those boys were great and could be better than normal people.
And so the eugenicist aspect of his work obscured how you genesis,
he was being,
you know,
he wasn't writing about the kids who he was deeming worthless.
So there was a silence and that historical record and that hasn't come out until
now.
Um,
and so if you take his word for it,
he's very benevolent.
Yeah.
Right.
He was fighting the pearls.
Yeah.
Among,
among the population.
So you said earlier that Lauren and wings definition of Asperger's syndrome
differed from his own,
and how so?
And tell me a little bit more about her work,
because this is the first I've ever heard of Laura.
Laura,
no,
wait.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
so she was the person who coined the term autism spectrum.
Asperger disagreed with her.
They met for tea,
it Maudsley hospital in London.
And um,
she believed that what Leo Kanner was describing,
which what you know today is called classic autism.
Um,
and what Asperger was describing were part of the same continuum.
Right.
Um,
and this is the autism spectrum as we understand it today.
Asperger really disagreed and what he published later in life,
you know,
I said he didn't publish much,
but what he did,
uh,
published was dedicated to showing that his form of autism was better.
And so he was calling canners,
uh,
kids,
psychotic and hopeless and irremediable,
whereas his kids,
he was even more hyperbolic about kids with Asperger's syndrome than he was
during the war.
So again,
the argument that he was stressing the special ability of kids to save them,
I don't think holds true cause he was even more glowing about these kids in the
postwar period when he was trying to separate himself from Canor.
Um,
so Lorna wing really saw this as part of it,
one continuum and Asperger disagreed with her on that.
But that's the part of the spectrum that then we've picked up from Lorna wing.
But at the end of her life in 2014 she said she ultimately regretted bringing
aspergers name into this because she thought that it become too much of a
concrete label.
Oh,
it is distinct from autism.
And that that did a disservice to her idea of a spectrum.
That's fascinating because in um,
in autism circles,
you often want to say,
oh yeah,
asked for.
It's the good kind of autism.
Yeah.
So it has even persisted.
You'll kid it'll be okay.
Yeah.
Subconsciously.
It's very interesting.
So what are the lessons you think we can draw from your book about how we treat
people in today's atmosphere of hype and awareness and the desire to act and
speak more inclusively?
We have a very active
group at Google,
um,
called the disability network.
Many of us,
our parents,
there's an autism group at Google.
And so we do work very hard here to be supportive and to create environments
where people on the spectrum can thrive because there's a,
an enormous range of intellectual potential that can be tapped productively for
a lot of the work we do here.
So what lessons do you have or modern companies,
modern societies,
schools around inclusivity?
Um,
I just think it's so important to look at people as individuals.
I mean,
labels can obscure far more than they can reveal.
And I can just say from my experience with my son,
people make assumptions about what he is like all the time to his core,
you know,
um,
he's one of the most empathetic social kids I know.
And if I happen to say he's on the spectrum or has Asperger's,
then they make assumptions that he lacks commute.
I would say that he's got my commute than anybody.
Yeah.
And I mean,
I think a lot of our stereotypes about autism today involves commute,
frankly.
Um,
we were told he lacked emotionality.
He lack capacity for relationships when he was diagnosed.
It was terrifying.
The kinds of things they were telling us about her son.
Um,
and over the years he's become him.
And as a mother,
it took me a couple of years to see beyond the label.
I,
you know,
I was treating him like a therapist.
These doctors knew better than I did,
and they were telling me things about my son,
you know,
that I was believing.
And it wasn't until after a few years of being at it that I got some more
confidence and was like,
no,
I'm the expert in Eric.
I might not be the expert on autism,
but I'm the expert on my son.
And so,
um,
you know,
I think the lesson is you just really need to see people as individuals.
So are you on a bit of a campaign to stamp out the use of Asperger's as a kind
of a definitional,
um,
diagnostic in this autism spectrum?
Um,
okay.
I have a couple answers to that.
First is,
uh,
when it comes to medical ethics,
I think the answer is clear that we should drop it.
There've been a number of Nazi era diagnoses that have been renamed.
So reactive arthritis used to be Reiter's syndrome.
And so,
um,
in medical eponyms are granted to either commend someone for discovering a
condition or to honor their life's work.
And so,
you know,
as I've outlined,
what Asperger defined as Asperger's syndrome has no bearing on how we,
we don't see kids today.
Psychopaths.
Right,
right.
Um,
and he doesn't deserve the honor.
So I think that answer is simple.
The problem is millions of people have this identity now.
Right.
Um,
and I think that's ultimately an open question.
But I do think in our culture,
Asperger's syndrome has taken on a bit of a eugenicist connotation.
And what do you,
can you explain to us?
For those of you who haven't read the book,
what do you mean by a eugenicist connotation?
Because that's a very loaded,
it are men.
It's very,
it's very clear.
Yeah.
I'm speaking from my own experience.
So my son has received three diagnoses,
autism,
Asperger's,
and PDD nos.
Oh,
I don't know.
Do you remember Pdd Nos?
Not otherwise specified,
otherwise specified.
Just see something.
Right.
And,
um,
you know,
when I would tell people he has autism,
they'd have a certain reaction when I'd say aspergers,
they'd be like,
oh wow.
You know,
there was sort of,
and it's the same kid,
but just different assumptions being made.
And um,
I do think that,
yeah,
there's,
yeah.
So time to stomp it out perhaps.
So do you want to talk to us a little bit about your thoughts and your research?
Uh,
on the term neurodiversity because the world is neuro diverse.
We are all neuro diverse.
Um,
but it's,
it's application is a little narrower in its common use.
Do you want to talk to us a bit about that?
Um,
I mean,
I can speak to autism is particularly
mmm.
Difficult.
It's unique in psychiatric diagnoses because they haven't identified a common
physiological,
MMM,
underlying condition,
right?
So if someone's bipolar or schizophrenia or schizophrenia,
um,
supposedly there's medication for that,
right?
Where's autism?
There's no one pill that you can take that addresses whatever it is you want to
address.
And so it's a heterogeneous diagnosis and we know that.
And they're likely to,
as you said,
with your son,
a different underlying causes,
genetic,
environmental for different kids that,
um,
and so in the book I liken it to where we were with hysteria a hundred years
ago.
Um,
which was a catch all term for women who couldn't control their emotions.
so if you think about it,
autism's a diagnosis for under emotional boys.
Interesting history as a diagnosis of sensibly male,
finally overly emotional women and hysteria at the time included epilepsy,
syphilis,
anxiety,
depression,
you know,
any kind of psychiatric disorder.
And it wasn't until medicine advanced that you were able to break it out into,
um,
and I think,
you know,
science recognizes the autism is an umbrella label and they're starting to break
out different subtypes.
Um,
I don't know where it will go,
but right now we just don't have a vocabulary that's adequate.
Um,
so when we say neuro diversity,
I mean,
I think especially with autism,
it's important not to make assumptions because it's not a coherent term.
Agreed.
Now I can keep asking questions.
I have many to ask,
but there are probably some questions in either the audience or on a dory.
Is that correct?
So it sounds like your,
um,
your path to this book was a little bit surprising to you at the start of it,
how you just went to Vienna for a conference and you happen to find this first
bit of research that you did.
Um,
from like the Nazi perspective,
how is the reception to your research as you started to uncover more and more
of,
um,
something that obviously was in contrast to the Po,
the common perception of Asperger?
Okay.
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Um,
so I will say when I came back from Vienna and talked to my agent who'd been
very excited about this Schindler's story,
it's like,
forget it.
Don't pay me back.
Bring me that.
Um,
so that was kind of remarkable to me.
And,
um,
as I was writing the book,
I was surprised,
I would speak with colleagues that would almost minimize,
I think,
um,
what he was doing.
So Asperger was transferring people to speak.
Oh,
grunty wasn't directly involved with murder.
Um,
to me it's completely a few transfer someone to Auschwitz,
you know,
what doing right.
Um,
and so as I was writing the book,
it was interesting,
I had a lot of conversations with people like,
well,
it's only a handful of kids and he did it in directly and what's the big deal?
Um,
so I was expecting a lot of push back when the book came out,
but I think to present the book with all its evidence was so undeniable that
I've been really pleased by how seriously people have taken it,
the body of evidence,
and that even though he wasn't directly holding the kids hands,
that people recognize how you know,
what he was doing.
Um,
so I've been really surprised and really gratified.
but yeah,
I guess follow up question to that.
Um,
it sounds like Asperger was never held accountable to what he did join the war.
how does that,
how did that happen?
Radios.
Sure.
So,
um,
the biggest factors,
I said he never joined the Nazi party,
so he was never purged from the children's hospital the way his other colleagues
were.
Um,
second is he himself claimed he was a resister.
He claimed that he rescued children.
These were all his own claims.
Schindler he was the good guy.
He was the good guy.
And um,
he was not widely known in Austria.
He was not a major perpetrator,
you know,
Austrian and German historians have bigger figures of interest.
So,
um,
his role was,
was not of interest to holocaust historians.
Um,
autism is not a big diagnosis and German speaking countries,
it's more of an,
um,
you know,
English speaking diagnosis or in other countries.
And so autism wasn't of great interest to German historians.
So you combine that,
he's not a big holocaust figure.
Autism sound interesting and this,
this just doesn't come out and people took his word for it.
I will say.
Um,
so in 1994,
that's the year Asperger disorder entered our diagnostic manual.
Um,
the American psychiatric association is supposed to vet names.
If you give an upon a misdiagnosis,
you're supposed to look into the person's background.
He wasn't even on the list of names to be vetted for the American Psychiatric
Association.
There was one doctor on the team that corresponded with archivists in Vienna
and,
um,
archivists would write back,
we don't,
we don't know much,
but one of the archivists wrote back like,
Whoa,
wait,
do some research because anyone in this position would have probably been
involved in some capacity,
but for various reasons there was momentum to get this into the DSM.
That's fascinating.
You know,
I don't know how many of you know Simon Baron Cohen,
but he is the father of Sasha Baron Cohen and he's also the director of the
autism research center at Cambridge in,
in the United Kingdom.
And what he,
he was very complimentary towards research and it said how Edith uncover is how
under Hitler's regime,
the profession of psychiatry became the eyes and ears of the Third Reich.
And that's kind of frightening when you think of,
uh,
the role of medicine and doctors in calling the population and making
determinations about who survived and who didn't.
If I could piggyback on that,
um,
the Nazis compiled her a Terry indexes whereby everyone had an index card or
this was the goal.
They got to about 12% of the population,
about 25% of the population in Vienna where they would call,
um,
medical records,
asylum records,
school records,
welfare records,
and to create a composite diagnosis of a person as a social,
as you know,
a vagrant is wayward.
There were all these kind of blurred sociomedical terms that were used at the
time.
So it's really medicalizing,
one's economic,
social status.
And so,
um,
yeah,
these index cards then became the basis of who would be forcibly sterilized.
Almost half a million Germans were forcibly sterilized in this period.
Um,
who would be granted permission to marry,
not everyone could marry.
Um,
and then of course deportations or,
or worse.
But,
um,
yeah,
the medical profession.
You know,
I,
in the book I talk about the Third Reich,
I like to see it as a diagnosis regime.
We focus so much on the outcomes of the concentration camps,
but that's really the last event in a series of decisions and the initial
decision whether or not to exterminate someone relies on diagnosis.
Right?
Is this person remediable or is it not?
And that begins with your index cards.
Right.
Um,
fascinating.
So you wonder if there's a modern day view of this whereby you have your DNA
markers and you have the ability to select for certain characteristics if you
are,
you know,
doing a lab built baby and it's all very interesting to contemplate and deeper
than we probably want to get into it.
Four in the afternoon,
uh,
here in mountain view.
We have another question from Ms Straw.
I just have one question from the dory or have a couple that I don't want to
take up all the time very quickly from someone in Cambridge.
She's watching at the moment and he says there has been much to be about how pro
or Anti Nazi various folks from the third wreck were.
Hans Asperger included here beyond correcting these historical facts,
uh,
Michael Asks,
what are the sort of further lessons that you would hope folks would draw from
your book and apply to today?
Um,
he asks,
what's a proper way to judge a person's role and responsibility within something
like that and what lessons can we draw from that to the contemporary time?
Wow.
What a question that really gets to the heart of human nature.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I think,
um,
there's a term that I like to use about the Third Reich,
the muddled majority where is few suddenly transplanted,
most Germans into Kansas,
they would behave completely differently.
Right.
But if you're walking down the street and you see a store that says Jews
unwanted,
do you go in and do talk to the shopkeeper or do you just keep walking by?
But then you might shop at a Jewish store to get better prices.
And so most people were inhabiting this world of gray and um,
you know,
I think
it would be nice and easy.
And if you watch star wars,
they're good guys and they bad guys,
but for most people living their lives,
it was really a muddled situation.
Yeah.
How I come down,
I think the case of Asperger's clear,
luckily for me,
um,
because if you're a conscious participant in the system of killing,
that's that right?
Um,
if you denounce someone who could be put to death,
that's that,
um,
I don't know,
walking by a Jews unwanted sign,
what does that do?
What does that mean?
That's something that's,
you know,
we live in a world of moral ambiguity now.
I mean,
we're doing things in our everyday lives.
I'm not going to,
yeah,
I don't want to get too political,
but we're all living in a world of gray.
Um,
but I do think it's important to illustrate that Asperger drifted into this,
um,
for careerist reasons.
He was trying to get ahead and I think it's just too important to be vigilant
and to at least keep a bright line about when you put someone in harm's way.
That's a very different thing.
All right,
one last one.
[inaudible] we're going to call it a wrap one last one.
Okay.
So from Sophie in Austin,
uh,
she says today,
unfortunately there are many biases attached to autism and this knowledge of
aspergers involvement in the Nazi era could potentially limit how someone
considers high functioning,
um,
and how they would understand the,
the diagnosis and the full autism spectrum.
Um,
do you have any suggestions going forward on how folks at can better communicate
what Asperger's versus the autism spectrum?
Um,
actually is do you have suggestions for particular language that's helpful for
people to use in place of the language that we've been using for a while now?
Um,
sure.
I wish I had a magical answer.
As I said,
we're just left without a good vocabulary right now.
Um,
where psychiatry is,
I personally tend to say my son is on the spectrum.
Yeah.
And then I describe,
you know,
the same way I described my daughter,
she has,
she's who she is.
He is who he is.
But um,
I dunno.
Autism.
I don't,
I don't like the word.
I think the,
I mean on the spectrum it's kind of benign and it invites conversation.
I do what,
what are your thoughts?
I mean,
I use
so does a,
it's a handicap.
It's a handy way of describing a set of behaviors,
but it doesn't begin to describe an individual.
And I think that's an important reminder to us all that the world is made up of
a beautiful mosaic of people.
And it is,
uh,
everyone brings their own strengths and their own skills to the table.
Some unfortunate people don't have sufficient skills to participate fully in
society,
and we need to care for those people.
I live in San Francisco.
A lot of them live on the streets right now.
They need care.
It's shocking to me to see how we have such a wealthy area walked away from our
responsibility to care for each other.
Uh,
but to be,
to recognize the bounty and beauty of the human condition and value each
individual,
uh,
is to me a very important reminder in,
in your work and in our,
you know,
day to day lives.
So with that,
this wraps another of our wonderful,
toxic Google series.
Edith,
I want to thank you so much for coming in,
for sharing your personal story and for writing this book and hopefully
debunking the myth that probably very much deserves to be debunked.
So thank you for all you've done.
[inaudible].